[Musique]
la Turquie c'est très connue des
journalistes en prisonniers dans du
monde mais moi comment journaliste kurde
qui était toujours censuréard sur les
par le police par le gouvernement
c'était vraiment difficile de travailler
comment un journaliste là dans un région
trop chaud en colère toujours mais
c'était pas facile en fait
[Musique]
c'est pas facile pour tout le monde la
turc aussi mais pour les journalistes
c'est plus difficile parce que les
journalistes sont toujours emprisonnés
sans harceler
censuré mais si vous êtes journaliste
kurde c'est 100% donc moi comment
journaliste après tentative coup d'État
en Turquie moi aussi j'étais en
prisonnier pendant 16 mois sans procès
dans un prison s'appelle la prison plus
sécurisée c'est pour le terroristes nous
nous étions condamnés de faire
propagande de taharisme dans notre pays
[Musique]
pour les cures de la France c'est un ami
très chaleur donc dans la région aussi
la France toujours soutient avec les
Kurdes et ici les peuple le citoyens
français ils toujours
m aide les Kurdes et soutiennent parce
que lecture des gens connus un grand
peuple s'en état sans pays là et les
gens toujours harcelés par la
gouvernement la dictatori en moyenne ou
rien
c'était première raison pour moi de
choisir France à venir ici
[Musique]